hello oh hey cam
it's chloe oh [ __ ] sorry chloe
god those surgeries are making you girls
look alike
hey kim i just thought chloe was you
isn't that funny
ding ding yum yum oh geez sorry kylie
hello oh [ __ ]
hey you uh which one are you again
what oh my god it's like that horror
movie multiplicity with michael keaton
wait now i'm confused who's who
court likes my ties i don't like mai tai
so i'm not
court okay that helps a little are we
our mom
yeah yeah what no all right everyone
shut the [ __ ] up if we panic we'll never
figure this out
okay the bottom left is kim because i
gave you that scarf for christmas
oh [ __ ] sorry kendall all right no more
sharing clothes
okay say i if you're the person that
wants to be a lawyer but there's no way
in god's [ __ ] he'll pass the bar
god damn it all right okay if you only
date black guys
[ __ ] that was a stupid question all
right hold on let me get jeff goldblum
he plays scientists in the movies
yes jeff we can't figure out who's who
oh yes i see we cloned
dinosaurs the same problem but
as long as you don't interrupt the
space-time continuum
nature will find a way
too late fat chloe's back i'm
rob oh
hi rob all right fun's over guys rob's
here
if you like that video click the link
below to subscribe to my channel yeah
if you click it i'll shuck your [ __ ]